individuals protesting right now outside
the grants or building that's where Joe
Moller joins us live with their message
hi Joe yeah hey there that group
actually left here a short time ago
signs in hand they were very frustrated
out here today they want to send a clear
message to the governor and to the
director of dieter now the people who
showed up today say they have been
waiting weeks if not months for
unemployment assistance they call and
cannot get through to any person to
answer questions one woman tells me
their online portal shows no issues with
their claim but they still have not
received money and don't know why they
say they are frustrated and worried if
something does not happen soon it drives
you crazy
you sit there all day long you you're
constantly on redial and then it'll tell
you oh our phones are busy now how do
you sit back and go to sleep at night
governesses lack knowing that you have a
city with over thousands of people that
haven't got paid
[Music]
well I've been talking to people daily
who have not got paid since March and
the concern is what they do next month
when they can't pay the bills now every
Friday Dior does hold those press
conferences like we were talking about
they're a virtual they're all done
online and questions are sent to them in
advance and then they answer the
questions that they want to now
regarding that that soundbite we had
earlier with a director when she talked
about the pending cases being more
complex people out here say that's not a
fair answer because this is taking too
long of many say three months it was way
too long to be waiting and they say they
plan to come out here in protest and so
issued as how it was all reporting live
at the Grant Sawyer building I'm Joe
mullet I'll send it back to you Joe